Let's go next to our caller from the seven
Oh eight area code. Who is calling today from
seven zero eight.
Does that mean?
Yes, it is.
Hello. This is Isaiah from, uh, Chicago. You
know, I saw on a backlash you got over the
last two videos about the Medicare for all
right. No, we're never gonna get it and that,
well, not never, but it's going to be awhile.
It was my point. Yeah, but go ahead, Isaiah.
No, I saying like, um, with me not being really
inspired to be even trying to vote in 2016
because those both candidates were so uninspiring
and as with me so than with millions of people
around, like we feel like it's a realistic
change within voting for Bernie because of
the things that he has promised has seen so
much realistically. So if you know what the
damper of the fact that we would never get
it. Do you feel it that way, like turn voters
off from getting into uh, trying to vote for
Bernie?
No, I w I w my hope would be that it would
actually get people to do more than just go
out and vote for Bernie in the sense that
if you recognize that there's going to be
way more to the fight for Medicare for all
than just electing Bernie, for example, that
it's going to be about, you know, someone,
someone emailed me and they said, you know,
David, even if we take the Senate and we get
60 votes, if only 10% defect and say we don't
want Medicare for all, it still wouldn't pass.
And so that's why this is going to be a much
bigger fight. I would hope that people would
say, Oh, getting Bernie in is just step one.
Then I've got to work at the Senate, I've
got to work on governorships. I've got to
lobby my member of Congress. You know, there's
a whole bunch of other stuff that hopefully
people would be inspired to do. The idea is
we're going to need to do more than just elect
Bernie. We can do it, but we've got to do
it. It's not just Bernie comes in and we've
got Medicare for all. That's my point.
I have one more question. Oh, that was a good
point as well. But on the Republican side
of things like we're burning, we're bringing
it back to Republicans that Bernie saying
that he would have Medicare for all bill.
That's changed. Like everybody stands. Like
that's something that you gotta have cause
it's like, Oh, I'm running for Medicare for
all. So what is a Republican run for in 2020
to try and give on? It's like, besides Donald
Trump's last, what could he really say to
spark his side of voters besides the last
that he's already taught?
Are you saying if you're Donald Trump, what
do you run on in 2020? Or if you are another
Republican, what do you run on in 2020?
Oh, Donald Trump.
Oh, Trump runs on, we know what he's doing.
He's running on keep America great. He's running
on the economy's fantastic and we're respected
around the world and we're doing the trade
deal. The U S I mean it's all lies, but that's
what he runs on. And if 62 million people
fall for it, as long as they're in the right
States, he wins reelection.
Okay. What's the for that, David?
All right, I appreciate the call. Thank you
so much, Isaiah. Let's go next to our caller
from the three zero five area code color from
three zero five. What's your name? Where are
you calling from?
Hi David. My name is Michael and Colin from
coral Springs. How are you? So I was wondering,
David, I saw your video like the previous,
um, previous caller in, uh, on Medicare for
all and it's unlikely hood, um, to pass. So
I was wondering, or actually I was actually
commenting on something I thought you might've
framed as being, uh, or framed, uh, wrong
and possibly made, uh, you sound a little
bit too dismissive about Medicare for all.
So that is, that is, um, I was wondering,
is it not true that Medicare for all does
not seek to ban private insurance, but the
main operation of private insurance or private
health care insurance in this economy, which
is, um, duplicative care, what will is what
it would be actually, and I know that came
out really wrong, but
no, you're completely right. It's, I, it's
been of widely incorrectly stated claim that
Medicare for all by necessity will ban private
insurance. I don't believe that that is the
case, but I'm going further. I'm saying that
to the extent that it is, uh, something some
people want to do, uh, I don't see legally
how you do it, but you're completely correct.
And I've made this during debates. It's not,
I don't, I don't believe most of the candidates
are looking to make private insurance illegal
that that's correct. I think that they shouldn't
try to, I think they wouldn't be able to and
it's been misstated before that, uh, they
all want [inaudible] [inaudible] but there's
also a mathematical reality, um, of unless
[inaudible] you have, uh, all service providers
accepting Medicare for all that changes the
numbers. And it was, it was not an argue if
it seemed like I was saying their goal is
to make, uh, private insurance illegal. I
was not seeing that. Thank you so much.
That is exactly what I thought. No, I appreciate
you clearing that up. Uh, that being said,
last question if that's okay with Elizabeth
Warren now detailing her plan on Medicare
for all, and I understand the point that you
were making an other video or one of the points
being that either way, all of this is the
Medicare for all is going to have trouble
going through Congress. I wanted to ask as
well now, uh, now that you see Warren's plan
for it, do you see Bernie's plan for it? We've
seen it for a long time now. What do you see
as more viable and does that possibly make
you lean towards endorsing one of them in
the future?
I don't see either of the plans as politically
more or less viable because I've already pointed
out much to the dismay of many in my audience
that in either case in either configuration
politically it will be a huge Hill to overcome.
I believe that Elizabeth Warren's uh, uh,
cost assessments, we're more unrealistic than
Bernie's. I have a problem with the way Bernie
is assessing predicted costs, but I think
Elizabeth Warren is even more off the Mark
with it, but they are big picture. They are
pretty similar plans in terms of uh, what
it, what it would cost and what would be included.
The how Elizabeth Warren, uh, would pay for
it. There are some differences there, but
we've got a long video about this which I
encourage you to check out. All right. Thank
you so much David. I appreciate the call.
Thank you. You too. Great to hear from you.